yo can you give me the uh
story about drive slow
man drive slow that's one of my favorite
kanye songs ever lay registration is my
favorite album yeah man that's a fire
playing pat um shout out to playing
pacquiao playing pat what up that's what
uh yeah he uh he he hit me up um was
like hey i know you uh you met kanye you
said y'all were cool i had i met him at
a uh at an interview we were all doing
like a big interview one time and i
talked to him about making them some
grills
and then from there that's what kind of
led to you know playing past saying hey
i know you met kanye you know why don't
we try to do a song together of course
i'm like yeah of course yeah [ __ ] and he
said yeah i asked kanye he said he down
with it but you know he might not use
your verse you know you might not use a
song at all he might take you off donda
you know what i'm saying that's that's
basically what he was telling me yeah
you might get on there he might not like
it so if you do don't be mad but it's
opportunity and i'm like [ __ ] you ain't
got to tell me i know what i was even
back then before he was just kanye a
producer right you know people didn't
really respect his bars but at that time
i did i loved his bars i didn't like his
beats i thought his bars was
way doper than his beats at the time
because that particular style when he
was sampling a lot of the samples yeah i
went into because right a lot of them so
samples didn't have the b the base right
right or they would have it but it would
come in and out so that they could
highlight the sample so you know this is
what it is i have my particular style i
like but it's bars i love
and i hear them talking about that how
people didn't want him to rap they only
wanted to make beats and i'm like what
y'all crazy this man was spinning but
you know when i had
even from then i knew the opportunity
was there amazing opportunity uh to get
on a song with kanye west and i didn't
think he was going to use it uh when in
there actually the verse i i did for
actually was the original verse i wrote
for sitting sideways when i did send
sideways at first it was
the first time i'd ever did a song with
big pokey and little kiki was on it too
and it was the first time i had ever did
a song with lil kiki
but the record label atlantic said hey
big pokey is not signed to anybody he's
an independent artist loki is not
signing anybody he's an independent
artist
you being me why all the artists who
signed the atlantic palo alto artists we
trying to push po albums the ones we're
trying to sell i know these your
homeboys but you can't put them both on
you put one of them on there and i'm
trying to explain like man look they're
not just my homeboys these are legends
the originators of the sound you know
these are the originators of the houston
culture right like it's bigger than just
somebody i like and listen to but they
didn't really see it or get it and i
don't know maybe they were right they uh
you know we ended up having to take
somebody out we took a little kiki off
big pokey was on the sample so i felt
like well
if he was on the hook so i felt like
well if we gonna sample him for the hook
we should give him a verse on there as
well you know and at the end of the day
even though it was my song i felt like
it's really big pokey song cause it's
his
his simple for the hook you know
uh but
i i originally had a verse that i wrote
because this is how i used to write i
used to get like brain fog so if i'm
anywhere and i hear music going i can't
think because the music is just it's
just
distracting me or you know i'm talking
to you i'm looking at the plaques on the
wall instead of focusing on my verse so
i would get a beat get the tempo maybe
come up with a opening bar
and then go into the bathroom where it's
quite going to my car outside where it's
completely silent and just right in
silence so all i can focus on is just my
verse so sometimes i do that come back
and lay it and the tempo will be a
little off because i'm
right in your car
yeah yeah not to the beat yeah i go back
in there and it's a little off so that's
kind of how it was i i went in there i
spit the verse my original verse which
ended up being the drive slow verse and
my boy t ferris was like it was me
little kiki and big pokey and right at
the very beginning of the song say is
it's big pokey
little kiki and wild baby but they had
to mute out the little kiki so it's big
pokey
and wild baby
when you hear it like okay damn they
didn't mute it out well anyway t vera
say look
man the verse hard nah i ain't saying
it's whack but it don't go with the beat
it just don't flow with the beat i rea i
really think you should write a new
verse because you already got to write a
new one anyway right to replace little
kiki's verse so i really think you
should write two new verses that go to
this song just try it and i was like man
you crazy this verse hard you crazy t
paris was like my coach he was like the
main person that believed in me he saw
the vision for it when i couldn't see it
when i thought i was over and done you
know in 2002 when i thought i was over
and done that was the end of my that's
what everybody in houston was telling me
too by the way i wouldn't [ __ ] without
committing there t fair come say
man look i believe your best day is in
front of you not behind you man i don't
think
you you uh better would come here
because y'all dope together but i think
you dope being yourself he really kind
of gave me that encouragement and
believed in me and when i didn't when i
thought it was over so okay he's telling
me
man okay this this versus hard but redo
it i'm like man you crazy then it kind
of snapped in my mind i could see the
disappointment in his face and he's like
all right if you don't if you don't
wanna you don't even wanna try this cool
you the artist it's your word whatever
you say i'm gonna go with it but i just
think you should try it's cool and i
said man you know what i'm letting my
cup i let my coach down man yeah phil
jackson called up a play i'm not gonna
beat scotty pippen on the bench now i
ain't going in the game right you ain't
give me the ball ain't gonna get now man
i'm my coach calling to play he knows
something or he sees something or he's
planning something that i don't
comprehend yet don't matter i'm not the
coach he's the coach yeah i gotta let
him do his job with coach and at the
very least i could try it and if it's
whack we ain't gotta use it so i said
okay i'm gonna try the two new verses
boom they're sent sideways but i had
that original verse in my pocket like
okay i'm i know i'm saying some [ __ ] on
here i'm gonna save this for
if you know jay-z want me on the verse
or you know what i'm saying or somebody
want me on something and i've been out
all night and i ain't got time and we in
the studio like man and it's a big major
opportunity i'll kind of use it for that
so when plane pad hit me and say i got
something i think and i say man first
thing i thought was man what ever said
when
and i used to say them because we'll
write out we'll write our verses
and sometimes you know the hard drive
will crash or something so if you don't
have it saved somewhere oh well it's
over rest in peace to your verse yeah so
i learned a lesson man i got to save
the written verses so somewhere i got
the actual written verse somewhere uh
you know i said lft yeah
it's coming man it's coming
for sure oh yeah well when it worked it
i laid it playing past say man look i
did it in my studio sent it to him
playing past say look kind of like it
but he wants you to come out here to l.a
and lay it because he got a few things
he wants you to do maybe something for
the hook maybe this he's got a lot of
ideas man bet but at the whole time i'm
thinking
at the end of the day my verse is not
going to be on there something is going
to happen to prevent my verse from being
either he's not going to like it i'm
going to be whack or it don't match or
something somebody the label not going
to like it somebody you know some i just
had it i'm sitting my mind i'm gonna do
whatever i got to do
ain't no way this verse going on there
man they taking me off of dondo man i
knew that man
but even when we landed out there man i
remember we landed in l.a
we were coming down the escalator lax
going to the baggage claim and as soon
as we get to the bottom of the escalator
two detectives one come to my boy goo
one come to me
say yeah when they start talking to us
i'm like man we getting punk because
mike jones had just got punked so when
you get pumped you punk somebody else so
i was like man they coming they trying
to try to point i think travis barker
got punk too so i'm like man i got it
from multiple angles i'm like man i i
hope i'm they about to try to punk me
man i ain't gonna punk me so i was ready
man i come down there detectives you
know they hey where y'all coming from
this and that i'm talking crazy to them
cause i'm thinking they're actors you
know you're like i'm about to go i don't
talk crazy to the police cause i know
what they capable of
[ __ ] and it's the l.a sheriff's
department whatever that man come on man
they easily could have come with us and
then [ __ ] it would have been a long
night for me but i looked at my boy good
he's just looking at me like crazy like
man what you doing man you talking crazy
i'm just talking disrespectful you know
just going off on them and then the
officer was on me the other he was
getting upset and the other officer was
like what was going on man come on let's
just go and then they just went to
somebody else they just wanted to check
out bags i don't know i'm just like
what y'all well i ain't got [ __ ] going
on you know [ __ ] gotta get to a kanye
session yeah so i'm thinking okay i knew
he was getting punked ain't no kanye
session you know whatever and then they
leave and i'm like wait where aston
could yet we ain't getting [ __ ] and
goo like now dummy we ain't getting
problem with you he's about to get us
arrested yeah
really have people out here [ __ ]
almost getting [ __ ] up in these
streets hey that ain't it then we went
to the hotel
okay i dropped goo off goose stayed at a
hotel and i went to the studio session
i'm in the car service going to the
studio session we pull up to the ho to
the studio the car the driver don't
exactly know where the studio is at
because it's not you know a big giant
sign outside it's a studio here right so
he pulls up we're in the left-hand lane
the far left-hand lane the studio is on
the right
we're at a stoplight
it's red
he say i don't know oh there it is right
there and he just break everybody off
it's a red light he just turned he went
far left hand lane he turned right over
three or four lanes of traffic and
turned right onto the street it just so
happened it was a cop right there that
he couldn't see he was getting blocked
so we get pulled over i'm like [ __ ] they
couldn't give me any part one at the
airport so now they're punking me i'm
like i knew it was too good to be true
doing some kanye man you know he getting
he getting a ticket all this kind of
stuff i'm asking the cop man can i can i
leave can i go and he's like yeah i
ain't giving you no ticket i'm like [ __ ]
i'm out i go do my verse i'm like [ __ ]
whereas the kitchen [ __ ] it ain't so
even even up until it came out it wasn't
until dj drama called me and he said hey
you want kaye album i was like i don't
know it ain't come out yet they might
have took me off down there right so so
[ __ ] like now you on here we i'm at the
listening party now come out tomorrow or
next week whenever he's like nah it's on
hill you on here i'm like damn no [ __ ]
like man and he's fired
how much of the song was like did they
just send you the beat or was the song
pretty much done when he sent when i
first originally did it was just the
beat it was no hook no nothing it was
just the beat and he was like it was a
concept the concept is just drive slow
but i didn't know like where he went
with his verse it was like you know be
cautioned you know be cautious when
you're living your life don't live a
fast life drive slow in your life you
know it was more
you know conceptually like a different
type of well i went slab with it you
know what i'm saying well i was talking
about really driving slow in the car it
was a little bit a little bit different
and glc came at the end
uh you know killed it too yeah shout out
glc man the whole the whole thing put
together man was
it was uh definitely you know when i
heard it when it was finished you know
what i'm saying it was definitely
definitely very different than when i
first laid my verse to it but you know
that's
that just goes to the vision of kanye
man when he got a vision for some man he
put it together man he's a genius that's
a big deal man it's a big deal hey
that's why i still ain't hey i know just
hey he can re-release that [ __ ] right
now without my verse and what am i gonna
[ __ ]
it ain't taking me off down the boat
wasn't there two versions of that record
it was like a live version right well it
was that version and then there was a
another version with ti with t.i like it
was like a kind of like a remix was the
same thing it was the same song yeah
just was with t.i's verse added and nti
put it on his album so that was [ __ ]
even then when we did the song we did it
on
kanye's album but craig calvin who was
ceo or i don't know what his title
president is something whatever he's
still there now in atlantic yeah he was
like hey how are what you think why oh
why don't we put that on your album too
and people don't do that and you know we
do that on the underground of course but
when it's a kanye west song man ain't no
way kanye letting you put his song on
your album so i'm like man
is he gonna do that for the label yes
man the label ain't no way the label
gonna clear right but jay-z was the
president of the depth jam let it go
shout out to hove shout out and then i
seen her over the mtv awards and he said
hey you know you owe me right i'm like
[ __ ] hey
i got
that's so crazy so that was originally
going to be on the original sitting
sideways diverse yeah the reverse
because the original since i was i only
had one verse and that was that was it
so when you go back to i don't know
maybe we need to do you need to do a
blend or that verse with the sin
sideways beat to see how it would sound
shout out to t ferris who's doing his
thing right now with megan yeah man
shout out t ferris who saw the vision
who's houston legend man for real if he
if he wouldn't have told me hey man do
something else then you know
the dominoes wouldn't feel that way they
did a big shout out to fairs